so y'all have y'all have any like over
drinking stories maybe for daytime I
heard that your mo I heard that your
most drug moments are with Blake Shelton
yes somehow your story that I have an
identical story with my bed and my
husband holding my hair because black
enemy when you were drinking yeah I just
started trying I thought had a baby in a
night this probably was her first I had
never really gotten sick from drinking
boy and so and it was Blake's fault
Blake kept handing me things like Irish
car bombs I'm like dude so I got to the
bus and I was like I've never felt that
feeling of spinning or you know and I
got in my bunk and laid down and Jimmy
goes you should put one foot after your
bucket light side around yourself gotta
settle yourself and then Kimberly so
sweet she opened my curtain she goes you
want a peanut butter sandwich yeah I do
I don't feel very good and then I woke
up the next morning and the peanut
butter sandwiches lame I blame Blake
[Applause]
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this